I wonder you came to the studio a few
days ago and you said I'm nobody's
punching back after that uh you made the
draw yesterday in a difficult position
with Sam you actually even had chances
to be better at one point and now you
took down probably your highest rated
ever player how do you feel right now
yeah I just I feel like ecstatic I mean
it's not something I ever expected and
yeah I mean I think a few years ago I
actually beat Wesley so probably but
definitely one of my highest rated
victories and yeah I just I don't know
it
I never expected it to happen and I mean
just a lot of things kind of went my way
and
yeah here I am again never thought I'd
see the studio another time here you are
and I'm sure it's not the last time now
take us through the game you guys played
this super aggressive line and you were
actually extremely well prepared did you
anticipate this line
um yeah it's actually a bit of a Funny
Story um I was having a dinner with a
professor at UFC and he just started
chess like maybe a year or two years ago
he's super into it but the one thing he
loves most is like all these crazy
gambits right and he was like he was
telling me like I wonder you gotta play
this Gambit and it wasn't this
particular Gambit um it was I think it
was um on move three Bishop C4 Bishop C5
castles Knight F6
and D4 and like he kept pushing and I
was like I don't know I'll have to check
I have to see like maybe I'll think
about it and I got back to my room and I
actually spent some time looking at this
I was like I can't play it it's just
it's too bad like you know it's like
almost the worst end game by force and
um but I did promise him that you know I
try to play some Gavin so so like I
never would have you know imagine
playing the scotch cabinet um if it
wasn't for him and it turns out like
okay it's probably at least not worse
for white so that's an accomplishment
and yeah after four Bishop C4 I was
looking at some lines in the morning I
was really hoping for like Bishop B4
check C3 like d take C3 BC like Bishop
A5 castles and then you know now we've
got like Queen B3 Bishop A3 E5 coming
yeah and it's like it's a lot of fun and
one of the interesting things is that
like LaVon is like a lifetime e45 player
um but like in his whole in his whole
career like both white is black like 4
000 games he's never seen the scotch
Gambit before so I was like okay you
could actually be a legitimate strategy
um but then he played Bishop C5 which is
the most solid move in like two minutes
and I was like okay you know that that's
rough like these 2700 guys just know
everything
um but yeah okay we kind of got
something and
did you prepare this at home yeah I
think it's it's kind of the main line
here um there's a snow white instead of
Knight G5
um but yeah white can also play C3 but
then okay Knight F6 and then we
transpose back into some Mainline
Italian yeah and yeah for a player of
lavon's calibrese got like you know like
40 moves of theory here there's no way I
could compete with him um but yeah okay
we got to this engine which is a little
rare
um but it has been played before
and D5 is the best move so he was like
he knew all this which I was yeah a
little sad to see but I think he got
ambitious maybe or because after c3d
castles
um yeah the main move here is Queen D6
instead of rookie eight and and then
white is forced to trade
um CD Knight takes on Knight C3 and then
okay there's like one trick here which
is if Bishop F5 which looks like a very
natural move then Bishop H6 is very
powerful and there's Rook D1 and F3 and
Black's actually worse
um open up the F5 yeah but he I think
instead of [ __ ] by five there's just
Bishop G4 and then okay I had like some
small ideas here but it should be very
equal yeah um yeah okay this is just the
end game with obstacle Bishops not much
um but yeah I think he he definitely
wanted to play for the win um but he was
just a little unlucky that like in this
line with rookie eight it's yeah Black's
um surprisingly like the king is very
unsafe and you are still blitzing out
your moves yeah I knew Queen G5 was
there and the night before surprised me
and yeah I think he just he told me
after the game he Blended Bishop D2
which is just very dangerous um because
Bishops once the bishop gets to C3 like
there's so many so many ideas and yeah
during the game um I actually thought it
was like very close to losing already
just because I couldn't see away from to
defend yeah um although I see like the
engine somehow finds something G8 first
but yeah
um but yeah during the game I actually
thought like and and he started like
spending a lot of time and I realized
that it's just very difficult
um yeah because I guess the main point
is Knight C2 Bishop C3 Queen D6 and then
like Queen H6 I I can just give up the
rook and yeah actually yeah after Knight
E3 I get the Knight back and Knight B5
is coming and okay all those pieces are
kind of dead in the water of the Kings
yeah you're getting checkmated yeah so
actually I'm not super sure like if he
had a better defense um well it's only
this King to G8 which is extremely
difficult to play and it's not even
defending that right right Bishop C3 the
game continues you go Knight a3n yeah
there's always long-term pressure
because yeah okay he can only exchange
his Knight for like either my knight or
my Bishop but you like there's always
his light squared Bishop is kind of bad
and his King is always weak so there's
always going to be more than enough
compensation and yeah I guess I was just
a little fortunate that he chose to play
for a win
um in a position that there's not really
many good ways to do so but still you
play the best moves after that like
Queen D6 Knight to C3 you spend some
time yeah maybe this was the first time
that you spend a lot of time on this
move Knight to C3 yeah Knight C3 was
kind of important because here I'm
threatening Queen H4 so if I play like
Bishop C3 or queen H6 first he goes King
G8 and then there's not an easy way to
like proceed with the attack like Knight
D2 and then um I don't quite remember
yeah probably he can just play Knight D5
here yeah whereas in the game like with
Knight C3
um I'm like basically threatening Queen
H4 and picking up the E4 Pawn yeah um so
he has to spend another Tempo on C6
um and yeah Rook d1n it's just yeah all
my pieces are coming into the game
everything comes with Tempo and you play
this move G4 very powerful as well
and at this point after Bishop page six
Bishop G5 did you feel any yeah here I
thought it wins in this game where you
could have lost the advantage after this
sure I thought it was still a little
complicated
um but yeah okay he he was also very
long time and I think
um practically it's just too difficult
like this F3 ideas that's Queen H7 I
mean none of his pieces on the queen
side are developed so so yeah I think I
thought practically that I should
probably win this position and
and yeah luckily I managed to convert
without too many for the issues well the
Wonder you should definitely call your
professor
thank you
patient comes from are you going to buy
dinner for him yeah maybe I'll buy him
dinner this is um no it's just it's
incredible yeah I never expected it
would happen um
but but yeah sometimes you know like at
the U.S Championship there's unexpected
results and yeah I'm just I'm really
happy to
tough played this game I wonder
congratulations once again a great
result for you and we'll see you in the
remainder of the games thank you so much
yeah our congratulations as well a huge
Victory indeed really